what's happening there reject nation
we're gonna watch ourselves three new
tv spots slash trailer ones are behind
the scenes and look another new look for
doctor strange and the multiverse of madness
movies right around the corner can't wait
can't wait people not at all what was that
so excited got a call multiverse is breaking
through and probably vibrating the table
the camera sits on just bad for business
your kids are gonna hate your jokes
hey you already do leave a like if
you can let's see what's in store with
whatever new footage there is to offer
doctor strange i always
suspected this day would come
because you always suspected this day would
come i'm ready it's a good line oh cool
wait what's happening whoa
and you're freaking me out for your
stickers i hope the real movie does that
i could use an avenger it's
about time you showed up on may 6
enter a world
in imax tickets on sale now sam raimi's
dr strange and the multiverse of
madness that is a dream come true sam
raymond's i got a call from my agent saying that
kevin feige and the marvel team were looking for
a director for the new doctor strange movie we
fired the first one it was really intelligent and
interesting so when that offer came and i thought
this would be a really good challenge ready to go
and a great return sam is such a lovely human
being and obviously he's standing in this
industry and this genre in particular is legendary
as it should be sam has become known for this
terrorizing cinema experience he's creating as
much tension as possible for the audience just
ready for them to have that jump scare moment how
much slime did they cover people in ways where
we were headed with the sequel to doctor
strange knowing that we wanted to explore
the mind-bending frightening side of the
multiverse yeah emphasizing horror here's
telling the story was such a gigantic
endeavor and there's a lot of
dimensionalized visuals that
we use in telling that story
we shot it with an eye toward that so i think it's
going to be a very exciting experience to go to 3d
you open this way between universes and we don't
know who or what will walk through it right
are they pushing 3d they sound like they're
pushing 3d i didn't even think about it but now
i want to see it in 3d i've never really been
like i have to see something in 3d but damn i
mean that first ad first that was like tripping
me i'm like am i processing this for the time
when i first shot full screen yeah and then i'm
like oh my god it's overlapping the letterboxes
is so bizarre and then for them to like directly
name check it like and to bring all this stuff
to 3d is really exciting like yeah i guess they
really do want people to go this is written by
michael waldron who was uh the show runner for the
loki series for heels yeah and i was reading today
for writing this he went back and really watched
like the spider-man films a lot just to have a
better sense of the understanding of sam raimi's
direction like the original spider-man films that
samurai made he wanted to really know how to write
in his voice do the script to his strongest suits
i think that's really cool because especially
when you get a behind the scenes like this like
how often do you get a behind the scenes that
are capitalizing on the director's vision the
director for an mcu film it's so common it's just
like it's the martin luther marvel film it's it's
an mcu movie and who's directing it i'm sure
they'll do an all right job cool and this really
seems like this is sam raimi's doctor strange
movie you kind of feel that like taiko ytd when
it comes to the thor films now like this is taiko
waititi's thor films this is like feeling like a
director's film again yeah absolutely and i mean
i hope the movie that's the biggest question mark
about the movie to me now is is how much of a sam
remy movie is this gonna feel like and i feel like
marvel and their creative committee whatever you
want to call it has like really improved and shown
themselves conscientious over time in terms of how
they keep their massive continuity in order but
also give the directors their vision and their
voice and i'm really hoping that this could be
not that he needs like a redemption but like a
true return to like you know sam raimi knocked
this big blockbuster movie out of the park well
what i love about the marketing so far for this
film is unlike with spider-man no way home which
was so heavily emphasized on what cameos are we
going to be getting and what supportive worlds
are going to be getting that seemed to be the
case for this film at first especially what are
the crazy cameos that seem to be the top focus
now whenever i see this movie being talked
about it's really focused on the main characters
it's really focused on doctor strange wanda and
that seems to be what the zeitgeist is focused on
as well this is like the exact effect this movie
needs to have where the cameos whatever they
may be are gonna be the cherry on top because
one is like stealing the show for me in all of
these spots even like that one line right here of
like try not to break the multiverse steven that
delivery on that line was just so damn perfect i
love it so much this movie's also getting bad in
saudi arabia you guys here oh yeah that's right
multiverse of gayness multiverse of gayness yes
sir try not to break the gate and stephen
let's keep it head rose in fact jesus wanted
to call me mr string please call me doctor strange
how gay are they making america chavez the gayest
guest yeah she's just going to be like walking
around putting her tongue down wanting his throat
that's right oh my gosh her and wanda are going
to adopt billy and tommy together by the end of it
together do it marvel first mcu lesbian couple
let's do let's do it the dimensional visuals look
great as much as sam raimi has emphasized that it
was like a lot of imagery is being pulled directly
from the comics i read the doctor strange oath run
and i thought that was wonderful and i reckon you
see some semblance here a lot of like house of m
visual image reach even that one shot that feels
very sam raimi-ish this is the only way it seems
to be like the doctor strange quote this is the
only way that that's not even right am i saying
that right this is the only is that the line
no my question that seems to be the quote that
i'm getting wrong because i hear a salad in
my mind's ear and it all just comes down to one
this is the way is mando yes this is the only way
that must mean he's seeing into the future
when he's saying that and that must mean he's
seeing a head yeah possible outcomes all right
guys well dr strange the multiverse of madness
tell me you're excited tell me what you're most
looking forward to about this film leave your
thoughts down below you can subscribe click that
bell hit that like button and hey let's do a pic
john tell us about rosa parra's multiverse oh
my god it's so freaking cool all right on this
timeline rosa parra mom film critic extraordinaire
different timeline rosa parra homeless vigilante
other timeline rosapara celebrity chef with a dark
secret her legs are fake a different uh timeline
rosapara is a firefighter she's super buff and her
name is lance door other timeline rosapara runs
the real rejects and she gives hilarious reactions
that she does with herself on a split screen
with another variant of her that's come over into
that multiverse they can bounce off of each other
double rosa double the pleasure triple the
fun uh hey another timeline of rosapara
she is her own child and her actual child is
her mother and uh hey different rosapar timeline
uh oh get this rosa is like really tiny right and
everybody else is average size and it's fun but
also very dangerous for her to exist in that way
different timeline rosipara is right in the shower